hey guys how's the gang it's Justine
welcome back to I always call it tech
Tuesday so clearly it's not a Tuesday
it's whatever today I'm going to be
unboxing and showing you guys something
really awesome and completely
unnecessary
I got so many tweets and emails and
texts pretty much everybody on the
internet who knows I'm an apple bin and
then knows that I have an Apple watch
that means they are tiny little vintage
Mac stands for your Apple watch it's
also pretty cool because you can just
lead your charger right through it and
it'll charge it's a nice little thing I
ordered this so thank you guys for
adding a special little treat it's a
dual charging car charger oh you are
Marian customer this is what
complimentary gift from us you think
thank you okay I was about to go see if
I paid for something that I didn't send
order but thank you so take a peek of
you this is the one that I really really
wanted but I think it since they had a
black version I had to get that one as
well can do a nice little comparison
office would be a great gift I love
gifting items that I've bought and then
unbox and then I give them to my friends
and they're like oh my gosh it's why you
open them oh my gosh
[Music]
this here will just pull through Excel
you can leave that table right good the
material feels pretty solid it kind of
just like a rubberized material
definitely would be make a great dog
choice because my dad would definitely
winter ripping this up so if you do get
this keep it away from the pup
it has a very nice rubbery smell to it
pretty solid pretty solid you want to
give it a nice test for you guys man
they look so neat I think what I'm going
to do is draw like a tiny little Apple
logo right there so it'll super
authentic the company's name is cold a
logo called the w3 stand comes in two
colors the black in the vintage tan or I
think it looks pretty cool and this is
now my new stand this is one that was
using previously is iPhone and Apple
watch charger so it's kind of good if I
pull up throw both of them onto there
this is really cute thank you guys so
much for watching hope you enjoyed the
big and these cute little vintage Apple
watch chargers to me I wonder what they
look like if I take off it I just take
off these entirely oh yeah this is this
is great let me know in the comments
below what you guys think of these and
let me know what you'd like to see me
cover next going I'll see you in the
next video
hey guys I'm so excited because the day
we are heading in to hang out Andrew and
Matt from the drone dude if you guys
know me or keep adding my videos I am
absolutely obsessed with drone the best
part about this video today is it's a VR
video so take a look around you're going
to be getting an entire immersive view
of everything that I'm seeing so let's
head inside and